(slow techno music)
- A lot of the work is quite repetitive.
The pleats took about two months to do.
Probably did those eyes 10 times.
Even the texture of the skin.
They're graceful, dancing,
which I wanted to portray.
That's the whole goal,
is to make them feel like
they're gonna swim away.
I'm Stephen Kesler, also known as Tusk.
I'm a large scale wildlife sculptor.
I found sculpture a little later in life.
In my late 30s.
Moving from one career to the other,
especially into the art world,
that's totally scary
and foolish thing to do.
I don't think I had an option
after I started sculpting.
I think my life was going to
be it, no matter what I did.
Sculpture as a whole has inspired me.
I mean it's a 24 hour thing for me.
Sleep just gets in the way, almost.
When I'm out,
doing day-to-day things not being here,
it's always running through my head.
I don't know if I'd personally
call myself a daydreamer,
but I could probably be labeled one.
There is definitely a calming with clay.
I usually work 12 hours,
for three days straight.
Being able to realize
what I want in it, quickly,
it just seems like it works
together with how I process.
I've been involved with making
three life size giraffes,
40 foot whale shark,
four Manta rays,
and we're working on this 30 foot iguana
behind me.
(fast pulsing music)
The humpback whales took
roughly nine months.
The inspiration to do these
pieces for the aquarium
was because Utah is a landlocked state.
There's a limited number of people
who see these in real life anyways.
To be able to be in the same room,
feel the size of it.
Hopefully there's an energy to it.
And hopefully inspire conservation acts,
because of it.
If someone says, "Oh, I can't sculpt."
I said, "Have you tried?
"Buy it."
You never know what's gonna happen.
Open the box of clay.
See what's in it, you know?
There might be a humpback
whale in the future.